And we'll do that with a clustering properties quiz.
>> Oh yeah.
>> All right, so what I'm going to do, is I'm
going to give you three different clustering algorithms. For each one,
ask whether it has these properties. Does it have richness?
Does it have scale-invariance? Does it have consistency? And so
the algorithms are all going to be variations of the first
clustering algorithm we talked about, single-link clustering. And so, what
we're going to do is we're going to run single link clustering,
but to make it a clustering algorithm we have to decide
under what conditions are we going to stop
building our clusters? And I've got three different conditions,
then that defines our three different algorithms. So
one is, we've got n items that we're clustering.
I'm going to stop when I've got n over
2 clusters. 'Kay? So just keep merging, keep building
clusters until you've reached n over 2 clusters, and
at that point, stop and return what you've got.
>> Okay.
>> Does that, does that make sense?
>> Yes.
>> All right, and you remember enough about single-link clustering for that
to be meaningful, but that's, it's where were
going to start off with everything in its own
cluster, and then merge them together by whatever
two clusters are closest together, and then iterate.
>> Yes.
>> Okay. All right, so that's algorithm one.
We're going to stop at n over 2 clusters. The
second one is we're going to have some parameter
theta, and we're going to keep merging clusters until we'd
have to merge clusters that are theta
units apart. And once they're theta units apart,
we're going to say, nope, that's too far to
be part of the same cluster. We're done.
>> Okay.
>> Okay? So that, again, it's a clustering algorithm, right? It's
going to take these distances, and it's going to turn it into groups.
>> So that's like, only things that are within
ten feet of each other could possibly be clusters.
>> Exactly.
>> Okay.
>> Right. Theta is going to define that. And the
last one is very, very similar. We're going to keep
doing clusters until we'd have to merge clusters that
are farther than theta over omega units apart. And omega
in this case is going to be defined to
be the largest pair-wise distance over the entire data set.
>> That's an omega?
>> Yes.
>> Okay.
>> And that's a capital D, at least now it is.
>> [LAUGH] Okay.
>> All right, good? So if you understand these algorithms, what,
what I'd like you to do is say which of these have the
richness property, which of them have
scaling variants, which of them have consistency.